l Imperio Romano, el Imperio Español, el
Imperio Británico… todos ellos dominaron
el mundo y terminaron cayendo.
Hoy vivimos en la era del Imperio
Americano.
Ya sé que a muchos os molesta que nos refiramos
a Estados Unidos como América pero, sin embargo,
todos sabemos a los que nos referimos cuando
hablamos del Imperio Americano.
Ningún otro país puede desafiar su poder
militar, con bases en lugares tan remotos
como GUAM, que es una isla perdida en mitad
del pacífico.
Y, creedme, esas bases militares son realmente
útiles.
Verás, el hecho de que puedas ir a cualquier
tienda de tu barrio y comprar un teléfono
móvil fabricado en Corea del Sur es gracias
a la globalización, sí.
Pero esa globalización no sería posible
si el comercio no fuera seguro.
Y todas esas bases militares estadounidenses
son las que garantizan que se puedan enviar
productos de un sitio a otro sin ser atacados.
De hecho, esta es la razón por la que Estados
Unidos se gasta tanto dinero en ejército.
Necesitan tener más presencia militar que
nadie… en todo el mundo.
Y, hasta ahora, lo han conseguido.
Sin embargo… las cosas están cambiando.
Hay alguien que está desafiando ese imperio
¿De quién hablamos?
¡Exacto!
De China ¿Cómo lo están intentando?
En este video te lo contamos.
Os voy a hacer una pregunta ¿Por qué creéis
que Estados Unidos tiene el ejército más
grande del mundo?
Pensadlo bien… en realidad a duras penas
necesitan tener defensa.
Fijáis en este mapa: Estados Unidos tiene
una protección natural: dos enormes océanos
que hacen que sea prácticamente imposible
invadirles.
Habéis oído bien, enviar tropas para atacar
este país es, prácticamente, una misión
imposible.
Pero sin embargo, Estados Unidos es el país
que más gasta en defensa.
Su ejército es el mas grande del mundo y
tienen bases militares en 70 países de todo
el mundo.
Reino Unido, Francia y Rusia juntos tienen
menos de 30 bases militares en territorio
extranjero.
Sin embargo, fijaos en este otro mapa: el
ejército estadounidense está en todas partes.
Y eso significa que ningún país del mundo
se atreve a desafiarles…
La jugada de China en el mar: ¿El fin del
crecimiento
pacífico de Beijing?
O… ¿Tal vez no?
¡Exacto!
En el vídeo de hoy vamos a hablar de CHINA.
Veréis, en VisualPolitik os hemos hablado
mil veces del progreso económico Chino.
Son la fábrica del mundo y muchas empresas
chinas se han convertido en los mayores rivales
de las grandes tecnológicas estadounidenses.
Pero hoy no vamos a hablar de economía sino
de ejército.
Más concretamente, de la presencia militar
en el mar del Sur de China.
Y creedme, no es ninguna broma…
Quedáos con este término: el “COLLAR DE
PERLAS”.
Seguro que en este 2019 que empieza, lo vais
a oír a menudo.
La primera vez que se utilizo fue en el año
2005, en un informe del Departamento de Defensa
de la Casa Blanca.
En este estudio se predecía que China intentaría
expandir su presencia naval a través del
Océano Índico.
En este contexto, el collar de perlas es una
metáfora donde cada perla sería una de esas
bases militares que China quiere construir.
Perlas que forman un collar que llega hasta
África y Oriente Medio, donde China importa
la mayor parte de sus recursos naturales.
Como os podéis imaginar, esta expansión
militar preocupa a todo el mundo… sobretodo
a la Casa Blanca.
Y la cosa cuando el gobierno chino intenta
“Tranquilizar” a la comunidad internacional.
Fijaos en lo que decía el ex presidente Chino,
HU JINTAO en 2009…
La carrera hacia un desarrollo pacífico es
una elección
estratégica hecha por el gobierno chino y
su gente.
Estamos en línea con la cultura tradicional
china, que ama
la paz, la tendencia de nuestro tiempo y los
intereses
fundamentales de China. –Hu Jintao
Hum… no se porqué pero esta cita suena
más falsa que el alma de Judas.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, en lugar de tranquilizar,
sirvió para asustar aun más.
Ya sabéis eso que dicen: excusatio non petita,
accusatio manifesta.
Pero… vale… ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
muchos: China quiere más ejército ¿Y qué?
¡Tienen derecho a defenderse como cualquier
otro país!
¿Por qué deberíamos preocuparnos?
¿De verdad quiere China superar al tío Sam?
¿Tienen posibilidades reales para hacerlo?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
LECCIONES DEL PASADO
Acabamos de decir que es casi imposible invadir
Estados Unidos pero… no hay regla sin excepción.
En el año 1941, Japan bombardeó el puerto
de Peal Harbor, en Hawaii.
Y un año más tarde, el ejército nipón
invadía las islas Aleutianas, en Alaska.
En ese momento, el Tío Sam aprendió una
lección: la seguridad es sólo un estado
de ánimo.
Y más nos vale proteger nuestros océanos
si no queremos que nos vuelvan a invadir.
Durante la Segunda Guerra Mundial, el ejército
estadounidense tuvo que luchar en montones
de islas del pacífico.
Islas que en muchos casos estaban despobladas,
perdidas en mitad de la nada, pero que tenían
un interés estratégico enorme.
Por ejemplo, la batalla de Midway, como su
propio nombre indica, se libró en el Atolón
de Midway, que es uno de esos puntos pequeñitos
que vemos en el mapamundi y que no sabemos
si es un error de imprenta, una mancha o una
isla real.
Terminó la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Por si alguien no lo sabe, Estados Unidos
ganó.
Pero… no olvidaron la lección.
No querían que algo así volviera a ocurrir
¿Y qué hicieron entonces?
Pues cubrir el océano Pacífico de bases
militares.
En todas esas islitas donde habían luchado,
dejaron un cuartel, con unos soldados de reserva,
aviones y barcos.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Para qué quieres tener
una base militar en un atolón como el de
Midway?
¿De verdad es tan importante?
La respuesta es sí.
Esas bases militares importan y mucho.
Pensadlo bien, mobilizar tropas de un sitio
a otro no es tarea fácil, ni mucho menos
barata.
Un barco de guerra es una ciudad flotante
con cañones.
En algunos casos pueden tener hasta 5000 personas
a bordo.
Y sólo pueden recorrer entre 500 o 1000 kilómetros
al día.
Es decir, que si queremos mandar un barco
de Los Ángeles a Shanghai, necesitamos como
mínimo 10 días.
Sin embargo, si ya tenemos una base military
en Guam, una isla en mitad del pacífico,
podemos tener a nuestro ejército en la costa
china en tan sólo 3 días.
Esa rapidez de respuesta es clave para disuadir
cualquier intento de ataque.
En realidad, muchos de estos barcos de Guerra
ni siquiera llegarán a disparar una bala
en su vida.
Con semejante poder de maniobra, nadie se
atrevería a atacarlos.
¡Pero no sólo hablamos de guerra convencional!
Muchos de estos barcos están pensados para
combatir piratas o terroristas.
Por ejemplo, el USS Independence es un barco
pensado para la lucha contra la piratería
¡Pero tenemos muchos otros barcos!
La marina estadounidense crece año tras año.
Y eso significa que nadie más en el mundo
les puede hacer sombra.
US Navy to add 46 ships in five years, but
355 ships won’t
come for a long time.
Por supuesto, todo esto le da un poder inmenso
al Imperio Americano.
Todo esto puede ser preocupante para muchos.
Pero, seamos honestos, hasta la fecha, ha
creado un marco bastante pacífico en el mundo.
Un entorno donde todo el mundo puede comerciar.
Allí donde unos piratas quieren bloquear
una ruta marítima, el Imperio Americano está
listo para darles caza.
Y esa es una de las razones por las que los
países del sudeste asiático se han podido
convertir rápidamente en líderes exportadores.
Y, por supuesto, todo esto beneficia a China
también.
Ahora vamos a ver cómo muchos países estarían
encantados de bloquear el comercio chino.
Y Estados Unidos ha conseguido evitar todo
esto.
Pero… ¿De verdad le gusta a China depender
tanto del Imperio Americano?
¡Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver!
¿UNA NUEVA HEGEMONÍA?
Muchos países están bendecidos con recursos
naturales: petróleo, gas, metales y todo
tipo de recursos naturales.
Tener recursos te da una ventaja enorme sobre
los demás países.
Ese es el ejemplo de Arabia Saudita, que es
lo que es gracias a sus enormes reservas de
zumo de dinosaurio.
¿Pero que pasa con los demás países?
Esos que no tienen recursos… esos países
que tienen que importar todo tipo de cosas
para sobrevivir.
Necesitan competir con los proveedores internacionales
y negociar contratos para garantizarse sus
recursos.
Necesitan asegurarse de que esos recursos
llegan a tiempo.
Y, en muchos casos, esto puede ser una posición
de debilidad.
Pues bien, este es el caso de China.
Sí, todos lo sabemos, China tiene una industria
nachovidaliana.
Pero… a duras penas tienen recursos naturales.
Todo su petróleo, su acero, uranio… todo
lo que necesitan para fabricar esos teléfonos
móviles y esas televisiones les viene del
extranjero.
Y cada día necesitan importar más cosas
¡Pero no sólo eso!
Una vez han comprado todos los recursos, tienen
que transportarlos hacia su país de forma
segura y barata.
Y por eso, el mar de China está cubierto
de marcos mercantes.
Es la clave de la supervivencia china.
Y por eso, a China le gustaría controlarlo.
Además, China no tiene un Mercado doméstico
tan grande como Estaods Unidos.
Casi todo lo que fabrican tiene que salir
a otros países para venderse.
Y eso significa aún más dependencia de esas
rutas marítimas.
Y, si recordáis otros vídeos de VisualPolitik,
el Partido Comunista Chino tiene ese pacto
tácito con sus ciudadanos: ellos garantizan
progreso económico y, a cambio, el pueblo
se deja controlar y no se queja.
Vale, ya sé lo que estáis pensando ¡China
no es el único país que depende del comercio
internacional!
Suiza tampoco tiene recursos naturales y no
parece que tengan problemas ¿Verdad?
Pues sí, tenéis razón pero… hay un detalle
que se nos escapa.
En el caso de China, bastaría con que un
país bloquee sus rutas comerciales y todo
el país colapsaría en unos meses… y creedme,
hay muchos países deseando hacer algo así.
Especialmente uno: LA INDIA.
Fijáos en este mapa.
¿Véis esa ristra de islas en el Océano
Índico?
Bien, esas son las islas de Andaman y Nicobar.
Y son territorio índio.
Sería muy fácil para la india colocar un
par de barcos de guerra por esa zona y bloquear
toda las rutas que llevan petróleo a China.
Casi todos los petroleros que vienen de Oriente
Medio pasan por el estrecho de Málaca, que
es donde está Singapur.
Y para llegar ahí, primero tienen que pasar
por estas islas.
Hablamos de casi 20 millones de barriles de
crudo al día.
Es decir, que si un día, el presidente de
la India se levanta con mal genio, puede hundir
a China en cuestión de días.
Hablamos de toda una amenaza existencial.
De hecho, el ex presidente chino, Hu JINTAO
se refería a este problema como el Dilema
de Malaca.
¡Pero no sólo hablamos de la India!
Estados Unidos no es un enemigo declarado
de China pero… digamos que tampoco es un
aliado incondicional.
Si la India quisiera bloquear el tráfico
chino ¿De qué lado se pondría el Imperio
Americano?
Difícil de predecir.
Y esto podría ser mucho peor que todas las
guerras comerciales de Trump juntas.
Así que ¿Cuál es la solución de Beijing
para todo esto?
Pues… ¡Esta!
La inciativa Belt and Road y su equivalente
marítimo: el
Collar de perlas.
Como sabéis, la iniciativa Belt and Road
comenzó con la presidencia de Xi Jimping
en 2013.
En principio, la idea es construir infraestructuras
en todo el mundo para acelerar el crecimiento
Chino.
Pues bien, el collar de perlas es la versión
marítima del Belt and Road.
¡Y no creáis que hablamos de poco dinero!
En 2017, Xi Jimping intentó sumar 124.000
millones de dólares extra para este proyecto.
La idea es llegar a los 900.000 millones de
dólares.
La idea oficial es que China promueve el comercio
internacional a través de los 65 países
que ya se han sumado al proyecto.
Y aunque la mayor parte de los líderes occidentales
rechazaron participar en esa cumbre de dos
días en la que Xi Jimping anunciaba el proyecto,
hubo otros grandes líderes que se sumaron
sin reservas.
Entre otros, Putin y Erdogan.
En efecto, esto es un encuentro de grandes
mentes.
En los
próximos dos días, espero que intercambiemos
puntos de
vista para lograr la iniciativa Belt and Road,
el proyecto del
siglo, que beneficiará a las gentes de todo
el mundo. –Xi
Jimping
Con China consolidando su poder y sus relaciones
diplomáticas en la zona, es cada vez más
difícil que Estados Unidos mantenga su hegemonía
en el Mar de China.
Si el ejército chino llegar a superar al
Imperio Americano, Washington perdería todo
ese poder disuasorio.
Y esto cambiaría las reglas del comercio
internacional.
Por eso, la Casa Blanca está muy preocupada
con todo esto.
La CIA ya ha dicho que los dos principales
problemas de Estados Unidos a día de hoy
son RUSIA y CHINA.
Y en el caso de China, la mayor preocupación
es su intento de ganar influencia en África
y el Océano Índico.
No somos tan inocentes… y estamos tomando
medidas de
contrainteligencia para asegurarnos que tenemos
todas las
defensas que necesistamos. –Thomas Waldhauser,
Comandante General del Ejército Estadounidense
en
África.
¡Pero ya sé lo que estáis pensando!
El imperio Americano llega a todos los confines
del planeta.
Y aquí estamos hablando, únicamente del
mar de China y, si me apuras, del Océano
Índico.
Por supuesto, tenéis razón.
En realidad, China sólo amenaza la presencia
americana en esta región concreta.
Pero hablamos de uno de los lugares más importantes
del comercio internacional.
Y por eso, la lucha es más que intensa.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque la historia
no termina aquí!
Los chinos no son tontos.
Saben que si construyen bases militares demasiado
rápido, Estados Unidos puede pedir a sus
aliados que hagan lo mismo.
Eso significaría una escalada militar de
niveles nachovidalianos.
Países como India y Japón se armarían de
barcos de guerra, flota aérea y bases militares
en toda la zona.
Y, seamos honestos… Estados Unidos y China
son como la extraña pareja.
No son los mejores amigos del mundo pero…
más o menos, se aguantan el uno al otro.
Pero tanto Japón como la India son enemigos
acérrimos de China.
Así que lo último que quiere Beijing es
disparar las alarmas y hacer que sus enemigos
se armen a sus puertas.
Y por eso, Xi Jimping mantiene un perfil bajo
y paciente en este tema.
Sabe que hablamos de algo a largo plazo.
Y ya sabéis que el largo plazo en China significa
muuuuy largo plazo.
Tal vez hablamos de un proyecto que llevaría
décadas.
Sin embargo, pese a que el ritmo sea lento,
más os vale recordar el término: STRING
OF PEARLS, el COLLAR DE PERLAS.
En los próximos meses lo vais a ver en todos
los medios de comunicación.
Hablamos de algo tan importante que, en VisualPolitik
vamos a dedicarle una nueva serie de vídeos.
Vamos a cubrir todos los detalles de este
proyecto ¿Qué pasa con los otros países
asiáticos?
¿Qué es eso que llaman la diplomacia de
la deuda china?
¿Qué rol juega la Unión Europea a este
respecto?
De todo esto vamos a hablar muy pronto.
Así que, ya sabéis, si no os lo queréis
perder, suscribíos a VisualPolitik y dadle
a la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones.
Mientras tanto, la pregunta es… ¿Creéis
que este collar de perlas es de verdad una
amenaza para la estabilidad internacional?
¿Qué puede hacer el Imperio Americano al
respecto?
¿Estamos ante el principio del fin del imperialismo
Americano?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Por supuesto, no olvidéis visitar nuestra
página de Patreon para apoyar este proyecto.
Este 2019 viene cargado de sorpresas y queremos
contar con todos vosotros.
Si os gusta VIsualPolitik y queréis participar
activamente en esta comunidad, Patreon es
el lugar indicado.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE,
compartidlo con vuestros amigos y, como siempre…
un abrazo y hasta pronto.